I've been telling you this week that some
prominent Republican players are turning on
Donald Trump, not over the Ukraine fiasco,
mind you, but over the Syria and curd fiasco
that we've been talking about, and as we covered
earlier this week, Donald Trump has pulled
troops from Northern Syria despite everyone
from many Republicans all the way to Noam
Chomsky agreeing that this is a very bad idea
to do, that Turkey will immediately attack
the Kurds if Donald Trump does that.
Trump did it, and immediately Turkey attacked
Kurdish forces in Northern Syria and now you've
got Moscow, Mitch McConnell, who's not pleased.
You've got Looney, Lindsay Graham, who's not
pleased, and Looney Lindsey is making his
displeasure known, but we need to do the political
analysis as well here.
Very rarely does Looney Lindsay go against
Donald Trump in a serious manner.
And here he is doing it.
Tweeting yesterday, quote, pray for our Kurdish
allies who have been shamelessly abandoned
by the Trump administration.
This move ensures the reemergence of ISIS.
Now Looney Lindsey happens to be right on
this particular issue.
Narrowly interpreted.
Remember when Lindsey Graham said that Republicans
would get destroyed if they nominated Trump?
This was back in 2016 when Lindsey tweeted,
if we nominate Trump, we will get destroyed
and we will deserve it.
Well, he happened to be wrong.
Donald Trump won.
But just a reminder that Lindsey Graham is
merely a guy who calculates the political
space that he is staking out.
So while Lindsey Graham happens to be correct
about the Kurds and Trump's decision to abandon
them, he's found something to critical.
Criticize Donald Trump over.
But remember that just months ago at the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings, Looney Lindsay delivered
what is maybe the most unhinged confirmation
hearing speech that I have ever seen from
a Senator on these confirmation hearing panels.
Do you remember this?
And please, I'm going to give you a few moments.
Get the kids out of the room.
This is not what I would want my children
seeing if I had children, a loony Lindsey,
and maybe the most unhinged confirmation hearing
speech in the history of American politics.
If you want it to FBI investigation, you could
or come to us.
What you want to do is destroy this guy's
life.
Hold this seat open and hope you win at 2020
you said that not me.
You've got nothing to apologize for.
When you see Sotomayer and Kagan tell him,
Lindsey said, Oh, cos I've voted for them.
I would never do to them.
What you've done to this guy, this system,
most unethical, sham, since I've been in politics
and if you really wanted to know the truth,
you sure as hell wouldn't have done what you've
done to this guy.
Are you a gang rapist?
No.
There's a guy who's making sense, right?
So listen, I have no praise for Graham.
He is a flip flopper.
Put my finger to the wind and see what will
get me some kind of attention type of guy.
He will sometimes come to conclusions that
sound logical or they sound remotely sane.
And then the next day he will take some outrageous
position that is the exact opposite of logical,
insane.
And case in point yesterday, Lindsay Graham
attacks Donald Trump because clearly Donald
Trump's actions are wrong to him.
And then he's at the same time, I mean the
day before, he was fighting against the constitutional
enshrined by the law impeachment inquiry into
Donald Trump.
He's a disgrace.
And in fact, as I mentioned earlier in the
show, this may all be calculated in order
to either distract from the impeachment inquiry
to set himself up to claim impartiality on
the impeachment inquiry because there could
be a broader plan here.
Trump doesn't have the ability to do non concrete
multi-dimensional thinking.
Trump can't do it.
Lindsay Graham is capable of that.
And so there may be a calculation here that
Lindsay Graham is saying, listen, I want to
oppose Trump's impeachment as strongly as
possible.
And the way to do that without appearing like
a mere reflexive partisan hack, which he is,
uh, would be to criticize Trump somewhere,
but then to come around and say, listen, I've
been as critical of Trump as the next person.
When Trump abandoned the Kurds, I criticized
him, but the impeachment inquiry is unconstitutional
and it must end.
I would not put it past Lindsey Graham to
be thinking in that way and to be calculating
along the way along those lines because in
the end, he's disgusting and we'd be much
better off if someone could defeat him a in
South Carolina and get him out of the Senate.
And he in the end, is still a participant
in as strongly as possibly maintaining the
Trumpy and status quo.
Even though he says he disagrees with Trump
on this.
Lindsay Graham's a broader positioning as
a Brown nosing sycophantic Donald Trump's
who defends the idea of Trump as president,
as anything other than a national atrocity.
That is not changed.
And until I see evidence that it has changed.
Looney Lin Lindsay is just doing what he always
does, which is putting his finger to the wind,
figuring out how he can make a statement or
make a political calculation that will get
him more attention.
That will get him more airtime or time with
the president or time in the media or whatever.
That's all that's going on here this weekend.
Okay.
We are doing a massive David Pakman show membership
drive.
It's going to be a one day membership drive.
We haven't done this for like a year.
We are blowing out membership.
Okay.
Massive, massive membership discount.
If you've been thinking about supporting the
program this weekend, you will have the best
opportunity of the year to do it at the lowest
rate.
If you want to be notified about this extraordinary
membership discount, sign up for our newsletter
on our website, David pakman.com very clear
spot there.
You can get our newsletter this weekend.
You will get an email and it will be a beautiful
thing for everybody who chooses to participate.
Let me know your thoughts about Looney Lindsey
on Twitter.
At D Pacman.
While you're there, follow the show at David
Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break, very, very much
news to discuss today with you,